- What is the craziest thing you've seen,
like since you've started "Botched"?
- I think it was maybe our second season,
we had a lady come on who had very large breast implants.
But they became calcified, so they were rock hard.
- [Kelly] Christ.
- She use to go out make a living
by breaking things with her breasts.
So we put a watermelon there.
- Yep.
- And she took her breast and she broke the watermelon.
I don't know if any of you saw that.
And then he held, what'd you have,
like a beer can in your had or something?
- A beer can.
- A bear can like this and she crushed the beer can,
right with his hand was there.
that was probably one of the craziest things.
- But she was so successful at it, she bought an island.
I mean she was actually quite wealthy doing those tricks.
- What?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Anyway, so this is crazy, all these things.
- Have you guys ever done anything
that makes you feel queasy
or you guys just have steel stomachs?
- Well that start off,
I mean when we started medical school.
And by the way, you started when you were young,
you were dissecting frogs and all that stuff.
- Yeah nothing grossed me out.
You know I could cut...
- So a little Hannibal Lecter but keep going.
(group laughs)
- I could cut up the frog or look at the bugs.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- But it's funny,
if you delivered me food that has a face on it,
I can't eat it at all, it grosses me out.
Isn't that weird?
- Yeah, me it took me until medical school.
We worked on cadavers.
- [Kelly] Ah.
- In the beginning you're kind of freaking out
but then then I looks, you know...
- [Kelly] You get used to it.
- After a while you kind of get used to it.
- But, and what you can do to help people too.
Like not just for aesthetic purposes
but actually like saving their lives, it's incredible,
what an incredible gift you both have.
- We're very lucky.
- I mean we're lucky to have this.
- [Kelly] Yeah, and not a gift,
you worked hard for it as well,
this wasn't just gifted to you,
yeah you have to work hard to be a doctor,
a lot of schooling.